the tabouleh season is on the line down
by two five seconds left
to pass the ball
I was the game I don't want to talk
about it boy I asked you a question how
was the game it was bad bad do you lose
now we want well
how many points you have zero zero
points David you're a six to 14 year old
how in the hell did you score zero
points I didn't play you hurt no I was
benched better player took my spot a
better player boy your mother would be
massively disappointed in you she was
still loved you don't think I know that
bill you don't think it pisses me off
knowing that there's someone out there
that's stopping me from playing the game
that she loved
I promised her on her deathbed I'd get a
scholarship just like her now David
almost went to your game today but I'm
glad I didn't because I would have seen
your sorry ass and on the pine I hate
you bill
who is he what Sid who's the kid that
took your spot he's a small knockdown
shooter named buddy buddy kind of stupid
name is that sounds like good like a
dog's name
exactly
what
I was benched for a Golden Retriever
named buddy
why yeah like there's an actual dog on
my JV basketball team and he starts
ahead of me how is that not against the
rules trust me every opposing team we
play asks the same thing but the ref
says there's not a rule in the book that
says the dog can't play the game it's
ridiculous
how does that even happen I mean he's
good he's like really good I don't think
I've even seen him miss a shot all
season let me get this straight you're
out of the game because of a dog yeah
and I can't even sub in for him because
he never gets tired because he's a dog
Wow what is your next game Tuesday why
are you gonna go I think so seriously
well I gotta see this basketball playing
dog for myself you haven't gone to a
game all year and now you want to
because you found out there's a golden
retriever on my team um yeah he sounds
incredible he's ruining my life buddy
has taken everything from me my spot on
the basketball team
my friends my place is valedictorian in
class my girlfriend
[Music]
and now now you look son I know things
have been rough for you since your
mother passed and haven't been the best
stepfather do you think it's at all
possible for you to arrange some way for
me to get a photo with buddy come on
bill what his name is buddy right yeah
his name's buddy
I mean people also call him Air Bud
that's good what look son
maybe basketball just isn't your spoon
you should go for football at all it
could be a good receiver the freakin dog
plays football too
what yeah he's golden receiver golden
receiver gone Retriever huh that's good
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]